i uh grew up in the soviet union
and uh fell in love with math early i
was forced into math early and fell in
love
through force that's good well that you
fell in love with other people well but
there uh something we talked about a
little bit is there such a
value for excellence
uh it's competitive
and it's also everybody kind of looks up
the the definition
of
success is being
in a particular class is you know being
really good at it
um and like it's not improving it's like
being really good i mean we are much
more like that with sports for example
we're not
it's like it's understood you know
you're going to star on the basketball
team
if uh
you're gonna start on the basketball
team if you're going to be better than
the other guys the other girls on the
team uh
so
that coupled with the belief this could
be partially a communist belief i don't
know but the belief that everybody is
capable of being great
but if you're not great that's your
fault
and you need to work harder and i
remember i had a sense that um probably
delusional but i could win a nobel prize
i don't even know what that entails
um but i thought um
like uh my dad early on told me
just off hand and it always stuck with
me that if you if you can figure out how
to build a time machine how to travel
back in time it will probably give you a
nobel prize and i remember early in my
life thinking i'm going to invent the
time machine and like like the tools of
mathematics were in service of that
dream of winning the nobel prize and
it's silly i didn't really think in
those concrete terms but i just thought
i could be great feeling
and then then when you struggle the
belief that you could be great
is like struggle is good that right
pushes you on yeah and so the other
thing about the soviet system
that might
love to hear your comments about is just
the sheer like hours of math like the
number of courses you're talking about
a lot of geometry a lot more i think in
the american system you take maybe one
year of geometry and high school yeah in
high school
first of all geometry is beautiful it's
visual and then you get to reason
through proofs and stuff like that in in
russia i remember just being nailed over
and over with you it was just non-stop
and then of course there's different
perspectives on calculus and just the
whole
the sense was
that math is like
like fundamental to the development of
the human mind
so
math but also science and literature by
the way
was also hit very hard like we read a
lot of serious adult stuff america does
that a little bit too they challenge
young adults with good literature but
they don't challenge adults very much
with math
so those two things um valuing
excellence
and just a lot of math in the curriculum
do you think do you think do you find
that interesting because it seems to
have been successful yeah i think that's
very interesting and
there is a lot of success people coming
through the soviet system i think
something that's very different to the
us and other countries in the world
is that idea that excellence is
important and you can get there if you
work hard
in the u.s
there's an idea that excellence is
important but then kids are given the
idea in many ways
that you can either do it or you're one
of the people who can't
so many students in the school system
think they're one of the kids who can't
so there's no point in trying hard
because you're never going to get there
so if you can switch that
idea
it would be huge and it seems from what
you've said that in the uh in the
uh soviet union
that idea is really different now the
downside of that idea that anybody can
get there if you work hard
is that thought that if you're not
getting there it's your fault
and i i would add something into that i
would say that anybody can get there
but they they need to work hard and they
also need good teaching
because there are some people who really
can't get there because they're not
given access to that good teaching
so
but that would be huge that change as to
doing lots of maths if um
if maths was interesting and open and
creative and multi-dimensional i would
be all for it
we we actually run summer camps at
stanford where we invite kids in and we
give them this maths that i love
and
the in our camp classrooms they were
three hours long and
when we were planning the teachers were
like three hours are we gonna be able to
keep the kids excited for three hours
turned out they didn't want to go to
break or lunch they'd be so into these
mathematical patterns
we couldn't stop them it was
amazing so yeah if maths was more like
that then i think having more of it
would be a really good thing so what uh
what age are you talking about is there
um
could you comment on what age
is like the most important when people
quit math or give up on themselves or on
math in general
and uh perhaps that age or something
earlier is really a important moment for
them to discover to be inspired to
discover the magic of math
i think a lot of kids start to give up
on themselves and
maths around
from about fifth grade
and then those middle school years are
really important
and fifth grade can be pivotal for kids
just because
they're allowed to explore and
think in good ways
in the early grades of elementary school
but fifth grade teachers are often like
okay we're going to prepare you now for
middle school and we're going to give
you grades and lots of tests and that's
when kids start to
feel really badly about themselves and
so middle school years we our camps are
middle school students we think of those
years as really pivotal many kids in in
those years are deciding yes i'm gonna
keep going with stem subjects
or no i'm not that this isn't for me
so i mean all years are important and in
all years you can kind of switch kids
and get them
on a different pathway but i think those
middle school years are really important
you